eight news now is your local election
headquarters
our i-team continues to report on the
ongoing legal battle
several people suing for a new election
had their day in court the i-team's
david charns here with the details now
hi david
hey kirsten so not one not two not three
but four
election related lawsuits in court today
it was pretty busy and these lawsuits
focus on either holding a new election
or preventing one now in the majority of
these cases lawyers asking for new
elections said
that there is rampant voter fraud but
the judges hearing these cases said the
evidence they're presenting is just
hearsay
and they said there was just no fraud
shown no evidence of that to sway this
race
now one of these cases involved
republican congressional candidate jim
marchand who lost his race by 16 000
votes
his lawyer argued clark county's
signature verification machine may not
have worked properly
and that the county sent ballots to tens
of thousands of addresses where voters
no longer live
93 000 ballots were sent to addresses
that were known
to not have active voters in them the
fact
that a ballot came back undeliverable in
a primary
means nothing doesn't mean these 93
000 people didn't change their address
and voted correctly
doesn't even mean these 93 000 voted
the judge threw out the request for a
new election saying the congressional
district makes up more than just her
jurisdiction of clark county she also
said the evidence shown doesn't actually
show any fraud happened
now in a different lawsuit a judge
denied a request to throw out
the entire election we're going to have
more coming up
at six o'clock about that for now i'm
david charns 8 news now